Allah
something it's not you to you're helping
evil fating uh fa fascinating
facilitating facilitating
facilitating yes for them the we have in
them when Allah said to cooperate upon
righteousness
[Laughter]
evil work in the shop he sells the book
but you didn't touch the book right but
I mean like you got the section for the
chicken or something
likei chicken maybe
maybe I don't know ask another
person I don't know
sometimes
right
[Laughter]
ald but you can ask us I don't
know which one I speak I spoke to him
many times man how are you speak well I
heard I overheard him that you want to
talk to that's why I give your message
that he want to talk to you the book
have you read the
book have you read the book I've read
some of the book I forgot to get I read
of the book
hang no it's read not chat just no no no
CH you want no no I'm looking for
someone sincere I am no no don't likee
to yourself man I don't want to have
your feeling you guys can ask something
if the gentleman gives me a book to read
I bother to start reading it and then I
say would you like and then he invites
me over and says you want to talk about
it I didn't talk about it I didn't say
that I said have you read the book and I
said yes you said you read some of it
yeah I started reading it keep reading
it keep reading it you know what you
need I'll tell you this one you need a
sincere because you know when you speak
to other brothers they don't tell you
this but I tell you the quranic style
I've not for anything to justify your
position with the argument doesn't make
any sense so I'll tell you pray to God
be honest you don't try and justify your
position h no because my position is not
by
necessity I don't mind any I'm happy to
talk to anybody about anything of course
what you do Sunday but we as a Muslim
when we talk like for example I I didn't
leave my family my wife and my daughters
just to come and talk we came here to
convey The Message of Islam so we look
for some sincere ones I spoke to you the
other brother spoke to you you know what
I'm saying so I adise you yeah read it
read it this book is Ser book
Mal yeah exposes exposes that the aist
are a nature worshiper they take Allah's
attribute and they give it to singular
at or they give it to uh random
selection you know that's what they do
but they use a very de deceitful tactic
to justify by using big
words oh you have umbrella
man there a clear sign not
you
have in which case I'll be happy to
share the Broly with you yeah you gave
me a
book what I find strange is up until now
as I understand it you've been somebody
who said religion is not about
philosophy yeah philosophy is for other
people yeah religion is about something
more primary than philosophy and
strangely enough I agree with you
because I think ultimately it's not
about intellect it's about your heart
and your philosophy has nothing to do
with intellect philosoph philosophy is
based upon skepticism to doubt
everything philosophy has nothing to do
with intellect in reality has nothing to
do with intellect people claim to be try
to say philosophy is using utilizing
intellect that's not true because what
do you think he Ching because why
philosophy is based upon a pure sorry
skepticism and there's two type
skepticism there's a blame worthy one
and praise worthy one philosophy deal to
the blame worthy one so you have to
doubt everything for
example skep me for example now if I say
to you uh there is something which is
know by necessity you got tell me prove
to me so you try to look for a proof for
something which is called self evidence
which doesn't make any sense like us
being here right now yeah no for example
when I ask you the question are you
certain that I'm speaking to you right
now you remember that question
philosoph no no that's not philosoph
philosophizing now no I'm not
philosophizing that's what I'm saying
you Tred to mix utilizing the sound
risen in with philosopy that's you're
saying I think some things that are
illogical yes yeah thank you okay we're
on camera shami is saying that I believe
some things which are illogical I point
out Shamy logic is one of the four
schools of philosophy it encompasses
ethics and medic and epistemology and
logic my problem with sh's position and
it's also a strength is that although I
think ultimately religion is about how
you live and how you practice and it's
not about being an intellectual or a
philosopher I agree nonetheless when
shami starts saying I'm being illogical
he is philosophizing that's what logic
is is a branch of philosophy you can
check
it if so before arist did the people use
logic the logic when you being illogical
you were saying I'm I'm asking I'm
asking you before aristot existed did
the people use logic
them you just told me the people did so
that's why I'm saying when you say
because I'm using this term you're using
more
logic
everything philosophers invented logic
before they came so okay so if and
you're using it so you're the world ofil
let us see if this if it's true or not
so is it if I said to you someone a bed
man never heard about philosophy nothing
and you tell him
that is it possible for someone to exist
and exist the same time and they say
it's not possible and this why we call
it illogical yeah he doesn't have to
know the term it's known by necessity
that's what I'm saying theal to say that
invent by the philosophers I don't agree
with that to begin with understand so in
Arabic
language okay so my point here is look I
to you are you sure he speaking to me by
the way are you sure speaking to me yeah
but I'm just want to make sure if you
have no but so there is possibility
you're not speaking to me correct yeah
corre so this individual possibility is
not speaking to me so therefore nothing
will convince him cre because they have
this which is blame worthy skepticism
which is which is it's not philosoph
take care ofself anyway